derrière ces barbelés un bâtiment qui
intrigue une vaste zone interdite au
public où se dressent deux antennes
géante
il se cache une horloge atomique
une horloge tout ce qu'il ya de plus
banal et pourtant ce boîtier
électronique renferme un matériau
radioactif
le césium un matériau qui al'avantage
d'être extrêmement stable dans le temps
dont conférence est fabriqué avec cet
équipement là un générateur de
fréquences très précis et très stable
c'est à dire que la précision de cet
équipement là et d'une seconde par
périodes de trente mille ans c'est donc
un temps universel coordonné ultra
précis que la station d'un louis produit
un temps de référence qui va être
envoyée à plus d'un million d'horloge et
dans un rayon de deux mille kilomètres
dans la nuit de samedi à dimanche ce qui
va se passer c'est que dans la minute
précédente au changement d'heure ces
générateurs de code horaires vont
envoyer via l'émetteur dalle oui une
information qui va dire à partir de la
seconde 0 de la minute suivante je vous
envoie le cône de changement d'heure
donc vous passerez tous à trois heures
tous
pas vraiment car le temps de l'émetteur
dalle wii et réservée aux horloges radio
piloter celle qui rythme la vie du
réseau ferroviaire français de la
navigation aérienne des autoroutes ou
encore de l'éclairage public
autant dire qu'il vous faudra passer à
l'heure par vos propres moyens